et en france le procès des attentats du
13 novembre se poursuit une affaire que
suit de près antoine boitel journalistes
au web sur rt france il a pu rencontrer
le chef de la berri qui est intervenu au
bataclan pour une boîte elle peut l'on
retrouve tout de suite
[Musique]
bonjour antoine rené bonjour de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau berthet france
à l'heure avec avec votre consoeur katia
technique vous êtes allés à la rencontre
de la br i à paris et plus précisément à
la rencontre du chef du groupe qui a
donné l'assaut dans le bataclan quelle
était l'ambiance alors c'est le 36 donc
c'est un lieu mythique avec une ambiance
très solennelle des sommes taillés sur
entraînés avec un mental d'acier on
aussi à quelques pas du palais de
justice donc de la cour d'appel où se
déroule actuellement le procès du 13
novembre qui est un procès historique
également tout de suite dans les lieux
quand on rentre au 36 du côté de la
mairie on se trouve face à l'énorme
bouclier sarcophage de type ramsès qui a
donc essuyé les vingt-sept impacts de
balles de kalachnikov dans le couloir de
l'assaut final ça donne un peu
l'ambiance déjà à prêts à parler avec
ses hommes on sent quand même une
certaine tension depuis six ans et
peut-être un regret celui d'avoir été
pas aussi bien
récompensés qu'ils auraient dû l'être
c'est-à-dire de notamment de ne pas
avoir obtenu la légion d'honneur même
s'ils ne la demande pas sa flotte dans
l'air des hommes antoine qui ont essuyé
aussi quelques polémiques également
alors il ya une controverse qui existe
sur l'intervention au bataclan eux la
suite d'un revers de main mais on peut
évoquer quand même le documentaire qui
était diffusé sur arte donc les ombres
du bataclan dans lequel on a vu donc les
co rapporteurs de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire de l'époque
c'est-à-dire georges fenech et sébastien
pietrasanta
il ya une phrase malheureuse j'ai
interviewé georges fenech pour ce
travail est une phrase malheureuse qui
là qu'il a dit qui qui
qui était de dire que le trajet lyon
paris de 2h20 était le même temps que
qui avait été nécessaire pour
l'intervention pour aller jusqu'au
couloir est donc éliminé les deux
terroristes en réalité
labeyrie elle défend un excellent bilan
c'est à dire qu' aucun otage n'a été tué
un policier a été gravement blessé à la
main mais on peut saluer tout de même
cette grande technicité et puis ce bilan
magnifique pour de deux terroristes qui
étaient prêts à mourir à qui avaient des
gilets explosifs avec des kalachnikov
avec ce comment dire ce grand coup de
chance au moment où le bouclier ramsès
tongs en fait toute la colonne est à nu
est le premier de colonne continue a
tiré avec son arme de poing donc un 9 mm
face à des kalachnikovs si vous voulez
ça fait pas tout à fait le même effet il
arrive à toucher un des terroristes qui
explosent par grande chance le gilet
explosif exposé vers un verre un mur
dans toute la mitraillette envoyé non
pas vers les personnes qui étaient dans
la salle parce qu'il faut imaginer que
dans le couloir en fait il est terrorisé
des des otages partout et les otages ont
tout de suite le réflexe de se jeter par
terre alors qu'ils en avaient devant les
fenêtres par exemple pour empêcher les
tireurs d'élite ce genre de choses donc
en fait c'est quand même trois heures
d'assaut de d'intervention pour une
minute dix de feu donc vraiment de
dassault est ce que les opérateurs
antoine ont gardé des liens avec les
anciens otages alors oui des liens très
forts jérôme nou lé jérôme donc le chef
de groupe de cette colonne nationaux l'a
dit les victimes les familles des
victimes les blessés ils ont droit de
poser toutes les questions à la berri
ils ont droit de les contacter ils ont
gardé ses liens très forts certains sont
devenus des amis
mais comment dire on l'entend aussi
d'ailleurs cette reconnaissance de la
part des victimes des anciens otages
dans la salle d'audience actuellement au
procès puisque tous et toutes comment
dire
salut la valable le courage et puis la
ténacité des opérateurs de la baie
merci beaucoup antoine pour travailler
votre article qu'on peut retrouver sur
notre site rt france point tv pour aller
plus loin justement sur ce témoignage
que vous avez recueilli de jérôme le
chef de la berri à l'époque merci